d'abord c'est l'un des animateurs
préférés des Français Michel Drucker
verrez bien ce verrez bien lui passer le
relais il plaît à toutes les générations
Fort Boyard a été l'émission qui lui a
donné envie de faire de la télévision en
plus de duels en famille et de Sam sur
France 3 il va officier donc plusieurs
prime sur France 2 il va reprendre aussi
l'animation de quiz du champion ou
encore 100% logique la carte au trésor
évidemment je pense que vous avez deviné
qui sait où il a déjà un prime c'est
samedi soir regardez
le quiz des Champions est de retour sur
France 2 10 champions
issus des plus grands jetés les deux
France s'affrontent autour de Cyril
Féraud alors qui va devenir le plus
grand ou la plus grande
chambre milord fructuer Floréal leur
culture générale et phénoménale de
quel objet
[Musique]
et fin de portable
ils ont donc les réponses avant même de
connaître les questions
Mireille est-ce que Paul va gagner ce
soir
[Musique]
retour gagnant pour le quiz des
champions samedi soir à 21h10 sur France
2 et sur la plateforme france.tv bonjour
Cyril merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors pour tous vous expliquer Cyril
devait être là demain mais Cyril est un
programme mais hyper chargé parce que tu
tournes tout le temps Cyril exactement
salut Pascal salut à tous mais je suis
ravi d'être avec vous ce soir mais nous
aussi on est très très content que tu
sois là gros programme chargé donc ce
prime sur ce samedi soir et alors tu
cartonnes parce que hier tu étais notre
top Cyril pour tout le dire tu pouvais
pas être avec nous en direct parce que
franchement grosse rentrée les chiffres
sont là le public est là très très belle
rentrée Cyril écoute c'est chouette
alors je ne sais pas combien j'ai fait
aujourd'hui puisque donc on a pas
d'audience et en tout cas c'est vrai
qu'on a fait la rentrée de slam et de
duel en famille avec un nouvel horaire
donc avec un challenge à relever on est
décalé d'une demi-heure on est on est
passé à 600 et quelques milles
téléspectateurs pour duel en famille
alors qu'on en faisait plutôt 400 la
saison dernière donc ça c'est déjà
chouette et puis effectivement
maintenant le pari c'est samedi soir
avec le retour du quiz des champions qui
est vraiment mon bébé c'est une émission
que je présente et que je coproduit
alors samedi soir on a un gros match de
rugby en face sur TF1 qui va nous faire
très mal je pense mais on va se battre
avec tous nos champions d'exception mais
oui évidemment tu as un programme très
chargé quels sont tes nouveautés aussi
cette année Cyril alors il y aura le
retour de 100% logique qui a été
vraiment un carton incroyable la saison
dernière 100% logique est quand même le
premier jeu auquel absolument tout le
monde peut jouer quel que soit son âge
quel que soit son niveau d'étude quel
que soit son niveau de connaissances et
un jeu auquel on peut jouer en famille
donc il y aura le retour dans quelques
semaines et puis l'autre nouveauté c'est
un énorme format qui s'appelle The Floor
qu'on a baptisé en France à la conquête
du sol je vous explique sans candidats
debout face à moi sur un sol géant
chaque candidat est propriétaire d'une
case avec une thématique qui lui est
propre une thématique qu'il a révisé
et ils pourront affronter en duel les
candidats qui ont les cases autour d'eux
pour les éliminer et le grand gagnant
celui qui remportera les 100000 euros
sera celui qui aura remporté les 115 de
ce sol géant et qui aura donc été entre
guillemets le maître du sol voilà on a
hâte de voir ça c'est un concept je
crois qui a été adapté c'est un concept
américain Cyril je parle sous ton
contrôle qui a été adapté au format
français c'est un concept hollandais en
fait qui a été créé par John de molle
qui est le papa de The Voice et de love
story par exemple voilà donc ça c'est à
découvrir très prochainement on se
demande quand tu dors Cyril bon tu es
alors Isabelle il y avait pas un
concours de de chant de chant de région
alors si bien joué Isabelle en fait on a
lancé l'année dernière la meilleure
danse folklorique de France qui a très
bien marché sur France 3 et donc cette
année on lance aussi le meilleur champ
folklorique de France et sincèrement
c'est une énorme claque je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi parce que quand on
avait fait la danse folklorique déjà on
était très touché par le fait de pouvoir
rassembler sur une même scène toute la
culture toute la richesse culturelle de
notre pays mais là le champ folklorique
de passer en une soirée des polyphonies
corses aux champs de berger des Pyrénées
au champ provençaux en fait j'ai pleuré
toute la soirée voilà c'est la première
fois que je pleurais sur une émission
vous le verrez bientôt aussi et tu
chantera parce que moi j'ai des
souvenirs de toi chanteur
l'envie d'aimer c'était très forte avec
moi sublime Cyril tu veux pas devenir
chanteur un jour non alors je dis
toujours que quand je serai viré de la
télé je chanterai dans une comédie
social parce que je suis passionné de
communier musical j'adore ça j'ai une
admiration sans limite pour les artistes
de comédie musicale mais je vais
peut-être encore faire quelques saisons
vous voyez ce que je veux dire ah oui je
pense vu ton succès tu es pas prêt de
partir de la télé les jeux juste une
question Cyril tu as pas envie parfois
d'élargir ton sexe tu fais beaucoup de
jeux ça cartonne ce que tu voudrais pas
parfois c'est pas à te diriger vers
autre chose des divertissements
peut-être un peu plus large en fait la
réalité c'est que je fais beaucoup
d'autres choses qui sont pas des jeux
quand je présente le Festival
Interceltique de Lorient quand je
présente musique en fait en direct sur
France 3 en direct de corrigidants quand
je fais fort Boyard enfin Boyard c'est
un jeu mais je suis un personnage moi
les jeux c'est ma passion c'est ce que
j'adore faire je pense que c'est ce que
je préfère fabriquer parce que
l'animation c'est une chose mais je j'ai
de plus en plus de plaisir à produire et
j'ai vraiment une chance dingue c'est
que j'ai pas été étiqueté animateur de
jeu on me fait confiance aussi pour
d'autres formats donc donc je suis
vraiment à privilégié j'en ai conscience
justement bravo pour ton bronzage et une
autre question que les dents
c'est incroyable parce que je pourrais
même pas citer toutes les émissions que
tu anime sur France Télévisions au
risque de déborder sur Touche pas à mon
poste tellement elles sont nombreuses
est-ce que France Télévisions tu as déjà
refusé quelque chose
non mais tu sais en fait c'est plutôt
alors on a déjà proposé des choses que
j'ai décliné ça c'est vrai et en
revanche c'est pas moi qui choisis c'est
à dire par exemple à la conquête du sol
le nouveau format c'est France
Télévisions qui me l'a proposé 100%
logique c'est France Télévisions qui me
l'a proposé je il y a deux choses pour
lesquelles je me suis battu c'est le
quiz des champions parce que j'y croyais
mais vraiment morticus je savais qu'on
en ferait un succès et ça a été les
premiers numéros ont été plus que qu'un
succès et duel en famille qui est une
émission donc que j'ai écrite une nuit
d'insomnie que j'ai créé j'ai imaginé
vraiment cousu main pour France 3 et
voilà c'est vraiment les deux programmes
pour lesquels je me suis battu après
j'ai de la chance c'est qu'on vient vers
moi pour me proposer des formats de ouf
quoi 100% logique c'est un format génial
par exemple la chance Pascal l'a dit la
chance que vous avez aussi c'est que
vous plaisez à toutes les tranches d'âge
y compris de la tranche d'âge qui
regarde beaucoup beaucoup France de
France 3 et qui se disent c'est le fils
le gendre le petit-fils qu'on aurait
adoré avoir une chambre Isabelle
vraiment et ce qui est assez touchant
c'est que j'ai vu l'évolution c'est à
dire quand on a commencé cela il y a 15
ans par exemple sincèrement c'était les
papy mamie qui m'arrêtaient dans la rue
ou alors quand c'était des plus jeunes
en me disait est-ce que je peux faire
une photo pour ma grand-mère aujourd'hui
avec Fort Boyard avec la carte au trésor
la carte au trésor c'est la cinquième
saison cet été on a fait notre meilleur
saison notre record historique donc je
pense que le public c'est élargi et que
je suis passé des papy mamie au papy
mamie plus papa maman plus tonton Tati
plus les enfants alors tu vas continuer
à cartonner mais vraiment bravo et merci
Cyril d'avoir été avec nous nous avons
trouvé un petit créneau parce que ton
emploi du temps est extrêmement chargé
merci de nous avoir fait l'amitié hier
par texto j'en peux plus rire en quatre
pour toi merci je te fais des cœurs tu
sais quoi voilà moi aussi je te fais des
cœurs bonne chance en tout cas on te
regardera et AntiVira et puis on espère
que tu viendras très très vite sur sur
le plateau de Paf quand tu auras un
petit moment à nous accorder on sera
très heureux merci beaucoup Cyril